Welcome to the deep dive on body, soul and spirit.
Let's begin with the physical body.
The physical body is often referred to in ancient Biblical scriptures as the Earthly Vessel.
It's the temple. It's the physical part of you that interacts with the physical world.
It's the house that occupies your soul and your spirit.
In the physical body part, you have the basic elements here.
On the screen, things like the senses such as sight, touch, taste, hearing, smell and so forth.
The physical body has a correlation to the soul.
When you're taking care of your physical body, you're eating well, you're taking care of yourself,
you're drinking fresh air, you're washing, you're cleansing well, it can help you feel good.
That's the next component here where we look at the soul component.
The soul is comprised of, and again, if we're looking at this from a Biblical reference,
it is our emotions, our will and our mind.
That includes the whole gammon of emotions that we can feel.
It's all the way from shame, which is one of the heaviest, hardest emotions,
all the way through to wonderful, expansive love.
We have the will and in the ancient scriptures, this is the part of us that wants to come into more of an alignment with a spirit.
The spirit is the part, again, this is working off the Biblical reference.
This is the closest to God, because God is in spirit and He communicates spirit to spirit.
So often, you'll have people going their whole lives, I was actually watching a video today where there was a lady who grew up in a very intelligent intellectuals,
cerebelly focused, so mind focused, that's the soul, family, where they had an initial belief in God,
but they rationalized it away with the intellect.
The soul component, the intelligence, was dominant.
Now, even in the component of the soul, you can meet people that believe all the answers to life are found through the cerebral intelligence, the mind.
The mind is the type of God or it's on the pedestal for certain individuals.
Now, I was one of these people, to a degree, where knowledge was my currency of value,
because I was a consultant, I used to help all kinds of people from grief and rape,
to elite athletes, to business leaders, and there was always a pressure on me to deliver results for my clients.
And therefore, the acquisition of knowledge, intelligence, human behavioral skills was very dominant in me.
Then there are other people you can meet where they're very dominant in their emotions,
and what they feel is reality, and they're very, very emotionally driven.
Now, you can have also people that are very geared towards the body, where the body holds information,
and what they're feeling, and what their body is telling them is reality,
and they're not necessarily connected so strongly to the spirit.
You can have people that love to just get the dopamine high or the adrenaline from physical activity.
They'll run a lot or train a lot, and these are great things, but this becomes their drug,
and they might be quite disconnected from their emotions.
They might be quite shut off, and so their way of getting safety or certainty is to work the physical body,
because it's easy, it's familiar, but to go into the landscape of their emotions
and to feel some of the uncomfortable feelings, to process their fear, etc., is just too difficult.
It's too uncomfortable, and so you'll have people who have that underdevelopment in one area
or an overdevelopment in another area.
I've worked with a number of mentors over the years where some were much more mentally focused
and others were much more about the body and the emotions, and the emotions have intelligence, and so forth.
Then you'll have many, many stories from all around the world where you'll meet super-intelligent doctors, scientists,
and then they have a near-death experience, NDE, they're referred to as,
or they might just have some type of supernatural encounter. This happens with my father,
where my father was trying to understand the Bible, for example, and he was reading the book of Revelation,
and he goes, I don't understand this crap, and this is all fairy-tales, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I guess I'm just, I can't do this, so his mind couldn't understand it, he tried, it didn't make sense,
and he was very frustrated and he went to bed that day.
And my father at the time was having also a bit of an alcoholic drinking problem, and then, boom,
he got hit by some type of light, he thought he was having a stroke, he kind of turned over and there was his light,
and it changed him in such a way. In fact, I was living in Europe at the time, and I got on a phone call with him,
this was pre-Internet, and all the Internet was just getting started, and he sounded so different, he was so kind,
I was like, I was looking at the phone going, what the heck has happened to my father, who is this man?
He had a spiritual encounter with the Holy Spirit, and this changed his life, and so you hear millions of stories,
not hundreds of thousands, it's in the millions, if not more, where people have an encounter in the Spirit,
and it changes them in a very, very profound way.
And so this is the realm of the Spirit, it's a little bit harder to describe than these other realms,
the physical realm is so well defined, everyone experiences that, some people just have an awakening of some kind about the emotions,
and the mental, and insights, and so therefore you can have varying degrees of dialogue with people based on their development at the level of the soul,
and you can have people who are really quite, they've had encounters here, the Spirit, and they really feel alive here,
but they're actually quite underdeveloped at the level of the soul, and they're not taking care of their body.
So again, these are ways to look at it, I mean I've seen people who are super spiritual, who believe God can do everything,
and I'm going to live forever, but yet they're overweight and not taking care of themselves physically, thinking God's going to do it all.
So it's interesting, you see where people's focuses are, and I can relate to this, where there was a period in my life,
where I was very focused on here, I had encounters, I had a number of experiences, and I started to believe that Spirit is everything, it's everything,
and in some ways it is everything, but I actually had a physical problem that needed a physical adjustment, some people describe this as the hardware,
so I had to stop having gluten, I had to stop having certain food, and my physical body started to heal,
and I was so surprised because I was so sure that it wasn't physical, I just thought everything's spiritual, everything is in the Spirit.
And then there are other situations where people spend their whole lives physically working and acquiring wealth,
because they think, that's the soul, the mind, the will, that all the solutions are in the physical material world,
they arrive at the pinnacle of what they thought they were going to achieve, and something's missing, and they're empty, and they go soul searching,
but the answer's not necessarily in the soul, it's here in the Spirit.
And so, again, a lot of times when people have NDE's, and these are the experiences, they struggle to language it, and I can relate to this.
I've had a number of encounters where I've heard music in the angelic realms, that you cannot play that music in this realm, it doesn't exist here.
And when I begin to describe it, I don't have the language, because what is language?
It's a pre-existing, shared set of words that we're using that you're listening to me through, that enable us to describe a particular thing.
But when I've had a new experience that's beyond words, it's from another realm, from the Spirit, it's, you can understand why, it's difficult to condense it down into language and into words.
So, it's really important to have this overarching awareness of these three levels, body, soul, and spirit.
This is the one where the Bible's very adamant that God is Spirit, and you can interact with Him in Spirit.
There's a story in my life where I physically got ill, my career was over in sport, I got into a relationship, I was long story short, I was absolutely broken at the level of the heart, the emotions, and the soul.
I was crying out to God, I felt I'd reached the end of myself, and all of a sudden God spoke to me in a voice so clear.
It sounded like Johnny Cash's song there, if you've heard that song.
And I was just like, wow, my God, why now, God, why now, why now?
It was my first question, because I prayed many times before and nothing happened.
And it was almost like this echo came back, I can't explain it, it's like telepathic, because it's beyond words.
And what I felt God say to me is that now you're ready, you're open, because all the realms of the soul and the physical, all the fantasies you had, all the things you thought were going to bring you, what you thought they're going to give you, the illusions, they didn't actually satisfy or satiate you.
Now you've come to a point where you've cried out from the depths of your being to me, and okay, I'll speak to you.
I can't explain it any more than that, that's just what happened in the experience.
And so this is, again, an overarching look at the body, soul and spirit.
And it's a beautiful thing to know the difference, and I hope you've got something out of this presentation, I hope you found it interesting.
And I wonder if you can reflect on your own life on where are you primarily focused at?
Are you someone that's always the mind when there's a problem?
How in touch are you with your emotions?
How well do you take care of your physical senses?
And have you had spiritual encounters?
And what are they like?
Now I will conclude in saying, in my vast experience on this topic, or vast experience that I've had, not all spirit is the same.
Not all spirits are the same, and they have a different intention behind them, and that takes experience to better work that out.
When you have had an encounter with the Holy Spirit or Christ, you do have extremely strong reference to be able to contrast other spirits that are out there, because there's a world of spirits out there.
And when you are open to that, you can sense that, and you'll be able to feel them and sense them, so your soul is involved.
Now the ultimate goal, as far as I'm aware in mystical Christianity, is to get the body to submit and obey the soul.
Why? Because you can't have your body say, I'm tired, I'm lazy, I don't want to do anything, I want to eat what I want, I want to do what I want.
Wait, the will is here in the soul, and the soul can rule over the body and say, no, we're not going to be eating that.
We're going to get up now, we're going to go for a walk, we're going to do this irrespective of how we may feel, or how the body may feel.
And so this is where the soul is to govern over our body.
And then ultimately we want the soul, and I've definitely had encounters of this where my spirit dominates my soul, and my soul is observing my spirit.
And that's a whole other experience altogether. Perhaps some of you have experienced that just yet.
But there you have it, that's the body, soul and spirit, and trust you've enjoyed it. Thank you.